- C'est donc un jour de
l'Indépendance sur fond de
fusillade et de fortes tensions.
J'en discute avec leleles-
Philippe David, président de
l'Observatoire sur les
États-Unis à l'UQAM. Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- D'abord, j'ai envie de vous
demander : les Américains
semblent à tel point divisés
qu'on peut se demander, qu'est-
q q qu'ils célèbrent aujourd'h?
CHARLES-PHILIPPE DAVID, prés.,
Obser. sur les États-Unis, UQAM
- Ah! C'est une bonne question.
Je dirais déjà que les
événements d'aujourd'hui,
le rêve américain se transforme
presque en cauchemar américain.
En réponse à votre question,
je dirais : est-ce qu'on célèbre
les États-Unis aujourd'hui ou on
célèbre les "États-Désunis".
Ils n'ont jamais été aussi
divisés etarararisés presque,
en tout cas, de leur histoire
qu'aujourd'hui. C'est vraiment
très difficile pour eux de
surmonter ces divisions. Alors,
évidemment, on peut se dire que
normalement une fête comme
celle-là devrait rassembler,
mais avec les événements
d'aujourd'hui, vous voyez à quel
point juste les armes à feu
encore, c'est un problème
qui est loin d'être résolu.
Vous avez vraiment deux sss
politiques qui s'affrontent
et il n'y a plus de centre,
il n'y a plus d'aile modérée.
Si on est républicain, on haït
les démocrates et vice versa.
D'ailleurs, je vous dirais
dans le jeu et la vie politiques
américaine aujourd'hui, rares
sont les républicains plutôt
démocrates et vice versa encore
une fois, rares sont les
démocrates qui seraient
républicains. Donc, vraiment le
centre politique américain est
agagagilisé et c'est dommage das
un sens, parce que la
majorité... pas écrasante,
mais quand même une majorité
des Américains paiaiaient à la
rigueur s'entendre sur le fait,
par exemple, qu'on doit
permettre l'avortement,
on devrait contrôler les armes
à feu et on devrait avoir
un processus électoral plus
efficace. Mais une fois qu'on a
dit tout ça, après ça,
les partisans, les activistes,
les groupes, les élites,
les politiciens contribuent,
alimentent, cette polarisation
qui dure depuis trop longtemps.
Si bien qu'on vient toujours à
cette idée qu'il y a toujours
deux camps, on dirait bien,
qui s'affrontent et il n'y a pas
de centre, il n'y a pas de
modérés, il n'y a pas de voix,
donc, qui se font entendre
autrtrtre de l'échiquier.
- Vous diriez que c'est la
faillite de quoi au juste?
- Je dirais que cette faillite
du discours civique e e cette
entente qui existait déjà
parfois entre les partis,
de ces ères qu'on appelait
une ère bipartisane qui a
prévalu, bon, il y a longtemps,
je dirais a été vraiment mise à
mal. Bon, depuis un moment,
mais surtout mise à mal par
devinez qui je vais prononcer
le nom ce soir, le fameux nom
n'est-ce pas, Donald Trump.
Donald Trump... les années de la
présidence de Donald Trump ont
décuplé et fragilisé à un point
presque irréversible cette
démocratie américaine.
omomommage est considérable
dans beaucoup de domaines
et à l'international,
d'ailleurs, comme dansvivivie
politique américaine
et la société américaine.
Donald Trump n'en est pas le
responsable, mais un peu comme
un pyromane, il a profité du
fait qu'il y avait déjà plein
d'allumettes et un brasier
pour l'enflammer et
de manière spectaculaire.
Parce que c'est vrai que
cette hyper polarisation,
elle a pris naissance déjà
au moins il y a une trentaine
d'années, au milieu des années
1990, et puis de présidence en
présidences s s choses se sont,
je dirais, gâtées.
Et Donald Trump, on dirait,
a i i i dans un méga cocktail
Molotov toutes les causes et les
racines de cette polarisation
pour la décupler et comme
je vous le disndndndre presque
irréversible ce jeu politique
extrêmement funeste
et toxique pour l'avenir
de la démocratie américaine.
- Tant et si bien
qu'aujourd'hui, Charles-Philippe
David, on aligne dans une même
phrase des mots qui auraient
semblé complètement farfelus
autrefois "guerre civile aux
États-Unis" en parlant au
présent, au futur proche.
C'est grave quand même.
- Oui, et c'est depuis
honnêtement l'émeute et les
événements du 6 janvier 2021
que toute cette thèse a pris
de l'ampleur et prend de
l'importance. Alors, avant de
arararer qu'il y aura
certainement une civile aux
États-Unis, il faut faire
attention. Je vous dirais qu'on
est à la croisée chchchemins.
Ou bien ils vont trouver
une façon de surmonter
leurs différends, ou bien ces
différents vont s'accroître.
Ça va dépendre des choix que
font les institutions et les
politiciens dans leur conduite,
dans leur discours, dans leurs
agissements politiques.
Et c'est vrai que là déjà,
par exemple, avec le jugement
Roe v. Wade, on a un exemple
d'institutions qui contribuent,
je crois, à cette hyper-
polarisation et à aggraver
la situation. Et ce n'est que
ébut. Imaginez quand Donald
Trump va annoncer, parce que
je n'ai presque pas de doute
qu'il va le faire,
qu'il va se présenter pour
les élections de 2024; ça a
l'air loin, ça s'en vient
tranquillement.
- Oui.
- Le jour où il le fait, vous
avez encore déjà toute une
psychose politique qui va se
déclencher parce que ça va
évidemment définir les termes du
jeu politique entre maintenant
et lctctction de 2024. On a
beaucoup parlé de Roe v. Wade,
écoutez, il y a une autre
décision qui s'en vient : Moore
v. Harper, que la Coupupuprême
doit... Elle doit annoncer
sa décision à l'automne sur
le processus électoral même.
Est-ce que les États les pleins
pouvoirs pour gérer le processus
électoral en vue de la prochaine
élection présidentielle et
définir les termes du jeu à leur
façon, ou il y aura encore
l'espoir d'une loi fédérale qui
existe pour en chasser la tenue
du vote et la tenue du processus
électoral? C'est la cour suprême
se rangeait comme Roe v. Wade du
côté de la version orilllllle,
que les États ont plein
pouvoir...
- de la constitution.
- ... et affaiblir donc ainsi
l'État fédéral, on va avoir de
gros, gros, gros problèmes en
prévision de 2024. Je vous
assure, ça risque d'être
vraiment pas une sinécure, cette
hirerere.
- Est-ce que vous voyez une
façon de remédier à tout ça?
Est-ce qu'il y a un espoir?
On voit déjà dans sososondages
85 % de la population dit que
le pays ne s'en va pas dans
la bonne direction. Est-ce que
vous êtes optimiste?
- Bien, je ne le suis pas, mais
j'aimerais trouver des lueurs
d'espoir. Et je vais vous dire à
l'occasion de cette guerre
épouvantable, absolument barbare
qui se déroule en Ukraine,
j'aurais pensé que le ralliemenr
une réponse qui l'est d'ailleurs
fort et musclé des États-Unis
dans les limites, évidemment, de
ne pas provoquer Poutine et
une Troisième Guerre mondiale,
et d'aider l'Ukraine, aurait
peut-être changer les idées des
éréréricains pour se rallier à
leur président. Ce qui est
arrivé dans le passé lorsqu'on a
une guerre.
- Oui.
- Bien, ce n'est pas vraiment
le cas; c'est-à-dire que
c'est le cas pour la guerre en
Ukraine. Oui, c'est vrai,
il n'y a pas beaucoup de voix
discordantes. Les Américains
sont assez d'accord avec Joe
Biden là-dessus, mais ça ne se
traduit pas par une popularité
plus grand du président des
États-Unis et il n'y a pas
d'effet delililiement sur
d'autres sujets comme tous ceux
qu'on évoque : armes à feu,
processus électoral, avortement
et ainsi de suite. Donc,
malheureusement, je pense que
déjà on va surveiller
les élections de mi-mandat qui
s'en viennent au mois de
novembre, et j'ai l'impression
que l'économie va être
le facteur dominant.
Bien sûr, l'avortement aussi.
Mais l'économie en premi
Et ça évidemment, ça favorise
les républicains parce
qu'on reproche à Joe Biden toute
la situation misérable sur
le plan économique, dans
laquelle les États-Unis se
retrouvent.
L'humeur de l'électorat ne va
pas s'améliorer et lesisisisions
au client fait référence je
pense que ça va malheureusement
s'accentuer etvavava prendre un
miracle pour les Américains
retrouve le sens des affaires
publiques.
- En terminant, est-ce que vous
pensez que les rats des
accusations portées contre
Donald Trump?
- Un autre sujet qui pourrait
enflammer tout le monde. Est-ce
que le ministre de la justice
prenante acte de toutes les
dépositions de tous lesdododocur
la commission du 7 janvier après
les témoignages et les
comparaisons va décider deportes
contre l'ancien président des
États-Unis? Ce serait la
première fois qu'un président
des États-Unis serait ainsi
traduit en justice et ça veut
pas dire qu'elle serait déclarée
nécessairement coupable au plus
haut niveau, la cour suprême...
mais imaginez une seconde
président des États-Unis
accusés. Peut-être même
condamner et l'effet sur
l'électorat je l'ignore.
Beaucoup de gens font applaudir
mais certaines personnes von